empowerment is an intrinsic motivation  that captures how much an agent is in  control of the world it can itself  perceive so an agent wants to be  empowered because it wants to have many  options that lead to different outcomes  choices that are actually meaningful and  affecting the world around it and as  such empowerment is intrinsically linked  to the agency of an agent to its sense  of self-preservation to the level of  causal efficacy it has in the world and  thereby it differs from these  arbitrarily assigned functions and  machine learning it is something that is  it's a kernel of the motivation of the  agent and not just some instrumental  goal but rather a basis that governs all  motivations and behavior of the agent  and can actually be used to create  specific sub goals for the agent itself